we can be heroes has been an epic
success on netflix but many fans have
been wondering what happened to
characters like max from the original
shock by a lavagirl movie
and now thanks to some crazy fun fan
theories we may well have the answer
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the top 7 shark boy
and lava girl fan theories about we can
be heroes
just before we begin many thanks to the
sponsor of this video raid shadow
legends
we will of course be talking spoilers so
take care
one of the most popular fan theories is
that max is actually
miracle guy given that shark boy and
lava girl are now adults it seems
plausible that miracle guy
is what max could grow up to look like
which could also explain how he knows
about the song that sharkboy sang to max
in the original movie cheer us up by
singing one of those little songs you
sing so well sharkboy close your eyes
shut your mouth dream a dream and get us
out
in fact miracle guy's snarky attitude on
display here
could be down to the fact that lullaby
ended up giving max nightmares during
his adventure on planet drool
max being miracle guy could also explain
why he's one of the most powerful heroes
in the heroics with a wide range of
abilities at his disposal from flying to
super strength and agility
remember that in the sharkboy and lava
girl movie after arriving on planet
drool
max learned that he also had powers of
his own i have powers more than any of
us
in that movie he was not only able to
run at super speed but he could also
conjure objects out of thin air
if we can be heroes is another of max's
dreams as some fans have suggested then
it would make sense that he'd give
himself an impressive set of powers as
well as a starring role in the adult
super team
but even if the film isn't a dream then
max may simply have made
his dreams of becoming a powerful
superhero come true in the real world as
suggested in the original movie
some dreams are so powerful they become
real so
dream a better dream than work to make
it real
one aspect of the theory that doesn't
work so well is how conceited an
attention-seeking miracle guy can be
just a quick selfie from my socials
while i start this thing and this
behavior doesn't fit max's personality
when he was younger however is possible
that as he grew up his character changed
and he ended up more like miracle guy
another theory about max is that he
could be the father of oho the
mysterious young girl who turns out to
be the supreme commander of oghima and
an
alien herself after all in the sharkboy
and lavagirl movie
max draws characters in his dream
journal that come to life
and likewise in we can be heroes orjo
draws creatures like the squiggle
monsters on her tablet and they come to
life
and could aho's ability to see events
that will occur in the future
be related to max's power to make his
dreams come true everything that is
or was began with a dream in a similar
way to how guppy doesn't have the exact
same powers as her parents but versions
of them
another fan theory that builds on the
idea of max being ocho's father is that
after the events of shark boy and lava
girl max became the ruler of ogima the
alien planet that occurs from
remember kids are the ones in charge
there according to this theory
later adult max ended up marrying the
alien ms granada and they had an
alien daughter who they called oho max
then decided to send his wife and child
to earth disguised as humans to set up
the plan for the kids of the heroics to
take over from their parents
on top of that this fan theory also
suggests that max created a clone of
himself in the form of miracle guy who
he sent to earth as well
an interesting observation made by dylan
keller is that the superhero mr positive
that linus was drawing at the end of
shark boy and lava girl has a similar
look to miracle guy
he's got a blue costume and a cape and
although mr positive's logo is different
to the h for heroics on miracle guy's
costume there does seem to be an
overall resemblance in their look it's a
curious idea but could this suggest
that lioness dreamed miracle guy into
existence
perhaps that's how miracle guy got some
of his less desirable qualities such as
when he tried to pick a fight with
sharkboy
another fun theory comes from the hyper
monkey who wonders whether max could be
wild card's father
the idea comes from the fact that wild
card has any powers he wants at his
disposal
there's not a single power in the world
he doesn't have and his only difficulty
is controlling that ability and so he's
never sure what he might
turn into or what power he might summon
teleport
heat vision now he's a toaster
max 2 was able to summon a wide array of
powers when he fought against minus in
the sharkboy and lavagirl film
creating all kinds of objects from
bubbles to butterflies and even a shower
of brains
if this fan theory were true then we'd
have to assume that wildcard's father
techno was actually the grown-up
max although they do look quite
different like young max in real life
techno doesn't have any superhuman
abilities techno is however great at
building gadgets and gizmos such as
jet packs similar perhaps to max's
talent and interest as a child
such as when he built tobor a theory by
tara4 is that marissa
max's crush in the sharkboy and lavagirl
movie could be missy's mother who's no
longer alive and we can be heroes
this theory points out that next to
missy's alarm clock is a picture of her
as a baby with her mother and hanging
over that is a necklace which makes
tara4 think of the magical necklace that
the ice princess wore in the original
movie
although the necklace on missy's bedside
table is different to the crystal heart
remember that marissa only got her
ability to freeze water and time when
she put the crystal heart necklace on
without it she didn't have any innate
abilities
which fits missy in her grandmother's
conversation about her mother not having
any superpowers
do you know who the greatest superhero
optimal was
it was your mother but my mother was
normal like me
what's also intriguing about this theory
is it implies the necklace on missy's
bedside table could have magical powers
and give her some kind of special
abilities
if she puts it on in the we can be
heroes sequel that's now in development
at netflix
i don't think that will happen but if it
did i imagine it wouldn't be a major
part of missy's story
as it would take away from the
deliberate choice writer director robert
rodriguez made for the character without
any powers to be the one who makes the
biggest difference
marissa being missy's mother leads into
another fan theory that missy's father
marcus moreno
is actually max who ended up with his
crush from the original movie
remember marissa drew a picture of ice
girl and dream boy together holding
hands in the first film
and in the new movie when missy's
grandmother says and without your mother
your father
never would have become someone who
leads by example
could she be referring to how marissa
saved everyone from the villain mr
electric when he came to the real world
and perhaps her heroic deed is what
inspired max to become the leader of the
heroics when he grew up the same way
missy inspires the new heroics to bring
out the best in themselves
one problem with this fan theory of
course is that adult marcus looks
different to what you'd expect in adult
max to look like and while people can
certainly be fur heard as children
and dark-heard as adults that doesn't
change the fact that the filmmaker cast
latinx actors as both marcus and missy
but
not max and while we wait to see if
we'll get more og
shark boy and lava girl characters like
max and we can be heroes too
it's a perfect time to check out raid
shadow legends a great game you can
enjoy on both your mobile and desktop
there's 10 challenging dungeons each
with a super tough boss that requires a
specific strategy to beat
as a movie lover you're sure to care
about story and raid has you covered
with 12 fully voiced story campaigns and
three levels of difficulty
then there are 13 awesome factions you
can use to build your team of champions
from dwarfs to orcs to battlelords and
the undead
and there are 460 champions to collect
each
totally unique with their own design
skills and strengths
no matter what you like raid's got
something for you the game is super
popular with over 200 000 clans fighting
and competing right now
plus there are over 25 million other
players to compete with
there's endless possibilities and
strategies for you to decide how to play
the game and there's never been a better
time to get started
the arena battles are one of the best
parts of raid where you can pit your
champions against players from all over
the world by winning medals and getting
placed in the arena tiers you'll
unlock huge rewards and bonuses to
upgrade your champions
raid's clan boss mode is also a lot of
fun as you team up with others to take
down some of the game's most dangerous
bosses and as your successes mount
you'll climb up the clan leaderboard to
earn some
awesome individual and group rewards and
last month raid just released their
biggest
ever update yes the doom tower has
arrived with 120 floors a bunch of
secret challenge rooms and 12
tough new bosses to take on it's a
perfect moment to start playing and
here's the best part
if you sign up today you'll get a stack
of free goodies and a super special
champion called bulwark
he's an extra powerful dwarf he'll get
you off to a great start in the tower
so hit the special link in the
description below to download the game
every new player will get an awesome
pack of bonuses completely free
including void champion bulwark an xp
booster
energy refills and an ancient shard
you'll find all this free treasure in
your inbox here
the offer runs for the next 30 days only
so grab these awesome freebies right now
by hitting the links below
now which of these we can be heroes
theories would you like to be true
and what would you like to see in the
next movie leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below
if you enjoyed this do leave a thumbs up
i really appreciate it
and if you want to discover more hidden
secrets and clues to everything you
missed in we can be heroes big twist
ending tap here to watch my twisted
truth video
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yupikai movie lovers